UK is getting warmer and wetter in fact
since records began all 10 of its
hottest years have happened after 2002
evidence from a new Met Office report of
our changing planet the top three
coldest years were all in the 19th
century so we've got a stark separation
between the coldest years in the series
and the warmest years in the series and
this is reflecting or emphasizing that
point that our climate is changing
[Applause]
there is now huge pressure from the
public to act the UK is committed to net
zero carbon emissions by 2050 part of
the Paris climate agreement that many
campaigners want rich developed nations
to go further and faster at the moment
we have targets through the we have
carbon budgets and the ones for 2030 and
beyond we know we're not going to meet
we need more policies so we need to back
ambition up with action how to make
progress is an issue that governments
all over the world are grappling with
but not everyone's moving at the same
pace in America climate change has
become a defining issue of the
Democratic presidential race and in
September leaders from all over the
world are going to gather here in New
York to make more commitments on climate
action but on the other side you've got
the Republican Party and Donald Trump
who doesn't believe that humans
contribute significantly to global
warming and who came to office pledging
to protect the fossil fuel industry the
u.s. is one of the world's biggest
polluters increasingly affected by wild
weather and natural disasters but an
awful lot hangs on the outcome of the
2020 election meanwhile the global
impact of climate change continues in
Europe record-breaking and deadly heat
waves in Greenland unprecedented
temperatures turning some frozen lakes
into pools of water elsewhere in the
Arctic like here in Alaska wildfires
burn some believe the concerning
headlines might actually be helpful
ultimately the biggest risk is not that
we scare ourselves with projections of
future climate change it's that we find
ourselves living in that environment
changed in all the ways that were
predicted and I think in the fight
against inaction I do personally feel
that alarmism and urgency is useful
climate change is here whether we can
change quickly enough to limit the worst
of what is to come a central question of
our time
Hanna Thomas Peter Sky News in New York